my guest tonight is a comedian and
actress who appeared on better call saul
and on pop tv's
florida girls she's also the host of the
hit podcast scam
goddess which is now part of the team
coco
podcast empire please welcome our good
friend very talented
lacy mosley lacey how are you i am
good now obviously you say i'm in a
vehicle
yes i see this now let me lay this out
for our viewers
um we were supposed to do a very
professional zoom interview
i've been doing them with everybody uh
and then
suddenly i have the scam expert on
the show and i hear oh there's a problem
with the zoom she doesn't have wi-fi
and the next thing i know about half an
hour later
you're in your car this feels like a
scam
this feels like a scam to me honestly it
is conan you know
my office is my car this is where i do
all of my business
this is so suspicious if i swear to god
if i didn't know any better i would say
oh you're
you're somehow grifting me right now
that's what's happening
just a little bit i mean conan i told
you you could come to my office if we
weren't social distancing and you'd be
right here in the passenger seat
that's where i do my paperwork when i
first heard about your
podcast i thought that you would be
i don't know making fun of people that
scam or putting them down
that is not the case you have great
respect
for people who scam you think it's an
art don't you i do
i if you're these are con artistes you
know
i love robbery i love fraud i just don't
want to see people get hurt
so if you're scamming the big bad guy or
you know evil corporations then i'm like
totally on your side
but if you're hurting people i'm not
into that like what you like to be clear
is you like the good kind of fraud
the good kind of felony the good kind of
corrupt deception that's the kind you
like
yes and believe it or not there is a
good kind i mean our government is
running so many scams on us what is a
parking ticket you put your car
somewhere and then some hustlers from
the government take it away and make you
pay to get it back
it's a scam so you think all
anytime your car gets towed you think
that's a scam
yes it is robbery and i've been told 12
times and that is not an exaggeration
you know what i think there's a i think
there's a 50
chance you will get towed during this
interview we will see
them first put a boot on your car and
then you're going to get jacked up and
you're going to be taken out
right and you're just going to keep you
in the interview i will the car will be
moving but i will
continue to do the interview carl will
be moving backwards and then you'll end
the interview at an impound lot
so you know until you brought it up i
didn't think about it but it is a
perfect scam
they put a ticket on your car because
they say what they're going to clean the
street
and then they take the car then you have
to go and
pay to get a car that you already own
back yes so it begins with the
street cleaning you think the street
cleaning's a scam
it is i've seen street okay so i
encourage people especially in los
angeles during covid when they stopped
giving tickets for street cleaning
like look outside is your street much
dirtier
is it i don't think so and i've seen
street cleaners give
tickets after the street cleaners
already passed and clean the street i'm
like no that's not right
right right they got to make that money
it's all a scam
now you see scams because of this is a
passion of yours
you see them everywhere right you see
scams everywhere you see scams when you
go to church
i'm told yes i go to a scam church
that i love very much uh like for
example like there definitely has been
like a sermon where our pastor will come
out
i will not say his name because child i
don't get in trouble but they'll come
out and they'll be like hey hello
congregation uh
i need y'all to pre-order my book in his
name amen
and you know i pre-ordered the book um i
also send my tithes via text and venmo
and they remind me uh yeah so there's
you know there is a vip section
oh wait you have a vip section in your
church yes
is it much is it much nicer is it like a
sports box at a stadium where you get to
have
free hot dogs and stuff what's so great
about the vip section
well one it's in the front and it's a
pretty big church
um it's not the seats aren't quite
different they just have like a little
velvet rope to keep you know the normy
jesus folks out
um and right now i do not sit in vip at
church but it is a goal of mine
okay so basically yeah it doesn't feel
like that's what christ was all about
was let the the people that are paying
the most come to the front that doesn't
quite seem like that was the message
you know jesus was turning water into
wine some would say that's bottle
service
you're right he probably did have a
bunch of scams going now that you think
about it
you know this guy's he was dead but now
he's alive lazarus
really okay we have to look into that a
lot of questions we have for jesus
and then he skips down he skips town we
haven't seen him
i'm curious about something you are a
single person
i'm guessing you're using the dating
apps as all
single young people are these days i'm
told
i go on every now and then and then my
wife gets mad so
um do you because you are a suspicious
person
and your whole life is about
uh scams you must have a
heightened suspicion and and sense of
mistrust when you're on a dating app you
must
you know i actually like dating apps i
feel bad for men on dating apps because
if you're
under if like you don't have this
problem conan because you're so tall but
like
if you're under five nine you get swiped
left on
so much on dating apps when in reality
if you met a man who was under five nine
in real life and you liked his vibes and
you liked him
you would not discriminate against his
height and um i like to tell everybody
that there's no such thing as five nine
no one has ever been five
nine no woman or man it's a whole scam
of a height
you don't think you don't think there's
anybody on earth who's 5'9
no there's not there never has been
we've been lied to
that's a hype that only exists on dating
apps yes
it is an imagination it is not real but
i'm side one so i can date you know
pretty much any height being so
close to the ground and always finding
change okay now i
uh i have met you in person and um you
are
a uh you are a smaller petite person at
5-1
and i'm curious was that something you
worried about when you were younger or
did you make peace with that right away
i've always loved being short and i was
hoping that i would be
short enough that i could get the
government benefits but by the time i
was 18
unfortunately i grew a little too tall
so that was disappointing
for me um there are government benefits
if you're
under a certain height is that right yes
yes there are okay um so you know and
and obviously it's not right to scam uh
you know disabilities communities and
things like that but i thought i was
legitimately going to be a part of it
um and i was bummed when i wasn't so
you got upset that you grew okay yes
um okay so describe how you find
dating apps how do you find them you
know what is your process for finding a
good dating app
i will you know when i'm looking for
love i'm looking for you know somebody
who will cook dinner
you know um get my dry cleaning uh maybe
organize
uh my receipts uh you know every week
and
um and as i started to say more i was
like oh i think i'm looking for an
assistant not a boyfriend but i am
trying to scam
a a man into uh being my assistant for
love
okay so that's basically what we want
you want uh
maybe there's two ways to go about it
you can find a man that you like and
then try to convince him to do all those
things
or you can hire a male assistant and
just then start dating him
oh this is a good point step into my
office
and which is my car yeah i can see that
yeah
i heard you say once and i don't
understand this you think virginity is a
scam yeah
it's a patriarchal scam it was just
created so we would all feel bad about
having sexual experiences or or to
control women
and so i always tell people that you can
have your virginity back it only costs
forty dollars to me um and then i will
send you your v card this goes for you
too conan i know you have a child but
that does not matter
i have two i have i have two children uh
but you know they're they're still on
the young side i
and i lost my virginity very recently it
was uh during obama's sec
it was during obama's second term and i
remember it very well
yeah second term obama yeah i'm so i
waited i
i waited i was very good boy um
or mentally ill i don't know what the
problem was but i know
um yeah i so so what you're saying is
you're going to sell people
for 40 you'll sell them a card that
restores them their virginity if that's
what they want
absolutely everyone can be a virgin
again and i want to make that happen
that's my gift to society if they come
across with the money
yes okay so your gift to society is
something that you're going to try and
make a lot of money out of
okay well is there such a thing as a
free gift you know we always get
something out of
anything that we do whether it be purely
altruistic
you know so i get it i get it i get what
you're saying you're what you're saying
is that everything
is at the end of the day some kind of a
scam
even if you're giving money to a charity
you get to feel good about yourself
because you gave money to the charity
so in a way you're getting something out
of it
exactly so yeah you get the feel good so
there's really just truly not like
an altruistic moment that doesn't give
you something positive in return
whether it's a good feeling or
encouragement
uh you know you still get something so i
get 40 and you get your virginity
okay all right well i would like that
card please i want my virginity back
because i'll send that right over conan
yeah thank you it was the
it was the best uh 42 years of my life
yes come on back i'll be in my office
on third street hey so you know what
something we've talked about this
and i think you might have something you
say that anybody who works in hollywood
in entertainment is really part of a
scam you think the whole town is a scam
absolutely we just get lucky if the scam
that we're participating in turns out to
be legitimate you know how many dark
alleyways i've gone down like oh i could
get an audition
or i could be killed
hey but you're like gotta see if there's
an audition down there
yeah yeah sure yeah you that was the
most cheerful way anyone's ever said or
i could be killed
or i could be killed uh that's the spice
of life in hollywood you just never know
but the whole thing about i mean when
you think about it
i remembered when i got started you know
taking
acting classes or improv classes and you
have to pay
and then they tell you you know what you
could use another round of classes
and you'd totally get the sense that
well i'm getting stage time but i'm
actually also laying out cash
that's a little suspicious it's a little
bit multi-level marketing
like you get to one level and they're
like oh but wouldn't you like to know
how to make believe an orange
you should take another improv class you
know so right
right there's tears and stuff but i love
it it's one of my favorite scams to get
involved in it's like a big scam where
we all know that we're paying money to
be seen on stage but we've all accepted
that we're being caught and then what
about like you say headshots
the whole idea of headshots that whole
industry if you got to get your headshot
you think that's a scam
oh headshots are definitely a scam all
you need to do to
get into the headshot game is shoot one
famous person or
famous adjacent person and then use that
picture till the wheels fall off
uh i once took photos with a
photographer who took pictures of denzel
washington's daughter
and i'm like oh this is very close to
denzel
and that's why you went with this
photographer yes
and he had me out on the street in the
middle of brooklyn dodging cars
in between photos and i just thought
that that was normal he didn't have a
studio
he was like much like i'm like this is
my office he was like this alleyway is
my office now stand by those bricks girl
[Laughter]
and did he even have a camera told me he
at least had a camera
he was doing a lot of this
that's a giveaway that it's just that
yeah the fact that no camera ever came
out
okay what's your advice if someone out
there is watching right now
and they aspire to be a scammer what's
your advice to them because you're such
an expert
my advice is confidence is key you know
everyone if scammers have something
that's so interesting to me which is
that
they feel like they belong everywhere
they go and they look like that way they
posture that way and so i'm always
telling people like really fake it till
you make it because nobody knows what
they're doing out here we're all just
throwing stuff at the wall
seeing what sticks so believe that you
can stand
believe you can con believe you can do
robbery
and you can do fraud so that's the most
inspirational speech i've heard
in a long time and i know that half the
country is going to disagree with me
but i do think part of the secret
formula for someone like trump
is he can see the results of an election
and just
with look in the camera and say nope i
won i won
and uh that's what's and he believes it
and he makes other people believe it and
then suddenly everyone around him is
going yeah oh yeah yeah he won
he's he might be the best he might be
the best at this ever
he's one of the greatest like when
you're talking iconic
con artists like he's up there that's
the mount rushmore he needs to be on
scam rushmore uh and his face and that
hair come on that hair is fraud
that hair is robbery let's not go after
weird hair
okay that's i sympathize with the man
and trust me that's been a big part of
my con since day one
is what i do is i a good car notice
distracts and so what i did is i
distracted with this
you got away with all kinds of [ __ ]
in the meantime
that's how i made it yeah you distract
code
i love a good bang all right i love a
good bang and i will say that
trump when i found out that they booked
the four seasons total landscaping
i for one didn't know if it was an
accident because i was like maybe
they're trying to save some coins
maybe maybe they did want to have it at
the landscaping between the
the shop and the crematorium yeah yeah
they needed to make some money
and uh they figured we'll get a lot of
press for doing this
and so maybe that was a scam maybe that
worked mm-hmm
it was cute um well listen it's been
very nice talking to you
yes and i'm i'm so glad that your uh
podcast
uh is uh is part of our of our little
team coco world
because it's fantastic uh you can you
can listen to lacey's podcast scam
goddess
wherever you get your podcast and if you
want to
um meet lacey just look for her
in her car that's where she does
apparently
interviews that's where you do your
taxes that's where you
that's where you meet a potential date i
think it all happens in the car right
it does it's multifunctional and code
and come by anytime to my office
i'll usually be on third street
okay i'll look for the plymouth valiant
on third street
and i love that as i do this interview
people are just walking by this is going
to be on national television
people are just walking by your car you
know what i mean
be so great if you rolled down the
window at one point and you ordered a
hamburger just through the window that
would be fantastic all right cody my
life is a scam i don't want it to be
this way but it is this is perfect
you know what when you think about it
this was an accident
but the fact that you couldn't get wi-fi
and you're doing it from your car
for you lacey and for what you're all
about it's perfect it's perfection so
thank you thank you very much and you
take care of yourself okay
you too cronin all right once you have a
nap now because i know you're sleeping
in the backseat